this video is sponsored by dashlane
conveniently store your passwords and
get 10% off with the link in the
description in 1997 a guy named Jeffrey
Bezos filed US patent 5964
11a a method for ordering items over the
Internet here's what it is instead of
adding an item to your shopping cart and
then clicking buy you'd just click buy
that's the whole patent it's so
comically vague because that's what
makes intellectual property so powerful
the wider the description the easier it
is to enforce just listen to this one an
apparatus for use as a toy by an animal
for example a dog to either fetch carry
or chew includes a main section with at
least one protrusion extending there
from that resembles a branch that my
friend is a stick both of these are
ridiculously broad but unfortunately
that's not uncommon what is unique about
Amazon's one-click patent is that they
actually use it usually these are filed
by non-practicing entities companies
that own intellectual property but don't
do anything with it instead they make
money by suing anyone and everyone these
two graphs tell the story first this is
the amount of patent related litigation
from normal practicing companies year
after year the number stays pretty much
the same and here are the trolls not
only are they way more common but
they've rapidly increased in just a few
years time and second roughly 87% of
troll lawsuits settled before trial
in other words patent trolls are very
common and very good at what they do
their strategy is fairly simple file or
buy as many and as broad of patents as
possible and then find people to sue
both they and the other company know the
cost of going to trial hundreds of
thousands or usually millions of dollars
so unless both parties are really
confident they make a deal the company
pays the troll just to leave them a
who by the way now has even more
resources to threaten even more lawsuits
you don't need much intellectual
property to see how this is a broken
system but the problem is actually much
worse than that
okay so you've got the next big idea a
zero clique mind-reading Buy Now button
here's what you need to know about
patents to get one your invention must
be novel useful and non-obvious you know
like a Buy Now button which buys now
totally not obvious anyway it also can't
be a law of nature an abstract idea or a
nuclear bomb sorry
I don't write the rules they usually
last 20 years
and unlike copyright patents are not
automatic in the United States you must
apply to the Patent and Trademark Office
and so long as your application has a
left margin of two and a half
centimeters and its capital letters are
at least 0.3 175 centimeters high it'll
be reviewed by an examiner with all the
speed of the DMV the process takes about
two years but the office does provide
patent themed Halloween and Valentine's
Day entertainment while you're waiting
seriously once your patent is granted it
prevents anyone else from making the
same thing without a license in other
words it's a two-decade
government protected monopoly so why do
they exist the answer you've probably
heard is pharmaceuticals researching and
developing a new drug is well gosh darn
expensive some say six hundred and forty
eight million dollars others 2.7 billion
whatever the number it's a lot without
patents they say no company would spend
so much when they could just wait for
someone else to and then steal their
idea someone could jump in and take all
the profit from the person actually
doing the work
sound familiar maybe so patents are an
incentive and not just to make things
you and I want but also to explain how
they work
because sharing knowledge is kind of the
basis for civilization this way when it
expires others can make it at a lower
cost or that's the theory
the issue is patents aren't always good
explanations in fact that's by design
because remember companies keep them as
vague as possible
technically patents should be so
specific that a person with ordinary
skill in the art could reproduce it but
technically they should also be
non-obvious
so yeah the other issue is that patents
aren't the only option Google's search
algorithm wd-40 and coca-cola all
famously chose to just keep their mouths
shut
trade secrets do run the risk of being
discovered but they don't expire in 20
years and they're still legally
protected so a smart company asks itself
can we keep the secret for 20 years if
not it should get a patent but otherwise
it'd be better off staying quiet because
of this patents may not disclose
anything that wouldn't already be
discovered what isn't really in question
is that they can be a good incentive of
course companies are more likely to
create something if it grants them a
monopoly the question is whether it's
worth it because during that monopoly we
all pay a price the higher cost they can
charge with no competition when your
phone costs $100 more this is annoying
when the World Health Organization
estimates 10 million lives could have
been saved with existing medicines and
vaccines it's downright awful and then
there's the problem of waste patents
like any economic system are a game and
when you add 7 billion players there are
going to be some unintended consequences
the obvious one are the trolls their
defense is that those who invent
something may not be the best people to
sell it
universities for example lots of
research but marketing not so much so
they say non-practicing entities buy
these inventions from say a school and
sell them to those who can use it but
ask those buyers
they shake their heads in this survey
92% of respondents said they added new
products or features from the license 0
to 10 percent of the time and they
rarely if ever prompted the development
of any new products in other words
companies had already invented something
and bought the license only to not get
sued Microsoft for example takes or took
money from HTC Samsung and Apple for
patents like scheduling meetings on
smart phones its phone was to put it
politely a failure but it still collects
profit and on a feature that nobody
hardly uses you might be thinking so
what who cares that the world's richest
companies are losing some money but all
these billions of dollars spent on
lawsuits is money not spent developing
new products or hiring employees when
Google bought Motorola largely for its
patents it spent 12 and a half billion
dollars instead of who knows what this
is what I call patent theatres in the
same way that so much of airport
security is just acting out the motions
for little or no benefit big companies
often file and buy patents not because
they actually need them but because
that's the game they need to play it's
not about innovation it's about not
getting sued chances are any one phone
company will violate another's patents
but file enough of its own and it can
threaten a countersuit it's mutually
assured destruction it might be better
if no one had them but someone does so
everyone has to while researching this
video I came across this article titled
the world's 50 most innovative companies
it's just a list of who has the most
patents of course number of patents
doesn't really measure innovation it
measures the well number of patents that
probably sounds obvious but it shouldn't
be their purpose is precisely to
increase innovation this should be an
accurate list it's not because of all
the unnecessary waste worse there isn't
really any one to blame examiner's have
to review half a million applications a
year
and under pretty stressful circumstances
mistakes will be made and companies have
to file patents or risk being targeted
there is a solution to all of this but
that's the topic of the next video and
just as patents protect companies from
theft today's sponsor dashlane protects
you from the theft of your online
accounts
the problem with passwords is that
they're just plain annoying and if they
aren't you're probably not using a good
strong password that's why you need -
Lane which remembers and generates
passwords for you your information is
kept secure and hey it's not annoying
just this year Facebook Under Armour and
British Airways have all had major data
breaches that's honestly pretty scary -
Lane encrypts those passwords scans the
dark web to see if they're being sold by
hackers and has a built-in VPN it syncs
with all your devices and you can get
started for free by clicking the link in
the description plus new users get 10%
off - Lane premium with the promo code
poly matter thanks to - Lang for
sponsoring this video and to you for
listening